[Music]
well congratulations you guys wrapped up
Dexter yes yeah big finale and you
couldn't even be in the country for the
finale right you were off I was in
Bangladesh working on a documentary
about climate change as part of a series
about climate change that's right I miss
producing but yeah I was I was couldn't
have been more gone right other side of
the world is you sort of I mean is it is
it interesting to be like you've got all
these dexter fans that are watching the
very last episode after all these
seasons and you're you're completely in
a different time zone yeah I didn't
really plan it that way I just sort of
worked out that way but yeah I mean the
end of 88 years for the fans at least
that was a big night but I wasn't there
and right now it's an end to I've
noticed today I was looking at the
research almost every single photo shoot
that you have done for Dexter involved
you with blood on your face yes and I
looked through hundreds of photographs
every time you went to a photo shoot for
dester they would say we got a great
idea and you're in this a little too
accommodated yes looking back and they
would dump blood good idea to go ahead
do it again yeah no yeah yeah a lot of
blood on the face I think maybe that's
over I don't know people will probably
still ask - could you just choke me or
lecture when people ask about your life
no but when you but when you see fans
they do want you to pretend to stab them
yeah yeah stab choked only if they've it
was yeah if somebody brings a prop
perhaps I'll use it but I generally know
not gonna do that you're not gonna do
that oral that part of your life is done
now no more of that no more blood all
over you know more please choke me yeah
well I don't know I mean there's I still
might be simulated murder or I'm
simulated and I like it and kill your
darlings there's a there's a murder in
that film yeah you uh you you're working
with the theme in your career we'll get
to that and kill your darlings you your
co-stars Daniel Radcliffe he is and it's
an odd couple it's Dexter and Harry
Potter in the same scene you're both
epic actors so obviously you get over
that immediately but what's it like
working with him he's great I mean he's
remarkably self-possessed and
intelligent talented for somebody who's
been famous since he was like 11 yeah
he's great but uh he definitely excites
the masses we shot beside a elementary
school one day and there were all these
kids just up against the chain-link
fence just Harry Potter Harry Potter
like a walking dead just yeah but he was
a May he was able to go over there and
and and speak to them and just let them
know that we were shooting and it would
be that he used his winter wizard powers
for good you know I would think if he
went over to kids and just said you must
all now be silent they would exactly
well that's basically what he did
they've never been more charged with a
sense of responsibility in their lives
and Maddy Potter told them to be quiet
right you could always pour blood on
your face and go over there kids don't
know Dexter right I hope no just did one
for bad parents yes
yeah okay when a kid comes up just and
says like I'm four I love you on Dexter
yeah you start to wonder what's
happening right right this isn't right
this isn't good I yeah I don't know I
have had people tell me that they feel a
real sense of guilt for having watched
the show with their kid while presenting
the kid as a fan of the show like we
watch it together I know it's crazy but
he loves you yeah and the kids just sing
crying